[Música]
estamos en conversación con jimena
terraza jimena bienvenida a radio canadá
internacional muchas gracias muchas
gracias por la invitación
jimena usted es doctor en lingüística
por varias universidades canadienses
también originaria de argentina y
trabaja ahora como profesor en un
colegio para jóvenes indígenas aquí en
la provincia de québec el colegio y una
para jóvenes digamos en un nivel
preuniversitario digamos
usted está presentando recientemente ha
presentado recientemente un libro que se
llama musrri o clip mus diría yo en
español una gramática para el estudiante
creo que tenemos y por qué tenemos que
por partes primero que es el muscle y
después vemos hacia donde desde donde
viene usted para llegar al mus cría esa
lengua es esa lengua perfecto el
monstruo y en realidad
es uno de los dialectos creek y el
cricket es una lengua indígena de canadá
que se habla en muchas provincias
canadienses
se habla también en quebec efectivo
evidentemente en ontario y presenta
diferencias dialectales diferencias que
son variantes como sería el español de
méxico o el españo en argentina son
pequeñas variantes y esta variante de el
cris es hablada en un territorio que se
llama la isla muchos factory que quedan
en provincia de ontario
y es un dialecto que es hablado por muy
poquita gente en este momento
contrariamente a otras lenguas de la
misma misma familia y del mismo contiene
un dialectal sea el crit de quebec es
mucho más tiene mucho más vitalidad que
el monstruo y habla de notario
ese es el que se del contexto un poco de
la lingüística alrededor de éste está
exactamente así
a mí me gustaría saber como una
argentina está agraciado preguntarlo
pero creo que vale la pena que nuestros
oyentes nosotros tus seguidores
entiendan un poco el contexto en el que
usted llegó a escribir un libro sobre
gramática de esta lengua tan específica
de estar de este como usted decía esta
vía de esta familia tan específica del
cric
como llegó usted a ahí exactamente bueno
en realidad hay que remontar un poco a
cuando su estudio en argentina es algo
de un vaca lo vaca logia decimos acá una
licenciatura en traducción con francés
español y vengo a quebec luego de mis
estudios para hacer un intercambio en
quebec descubro que hay una ley para
proteger el francés hay una como mucho
trabajo que se ha hecho con la lengua
entonces tomó un curso en el que
hablamos de todas estas medidas que se
toman en el mundo es un es un ámbito de
la lingüística se llama planificación
lingüística es lo que han hecho en el
país vasco también
e incluir en las escuelas poner leyes
para protegerlo etcétera y la gente me
preguntaba y en argentina y entonces
bueno en argentina y ahí descubrí que en
argentina mira de la época que eso se
había pasado por la universidad y sin
embargo todavía hay como había como un
desconocimiento en esa época de lo que
era la diversidad lingüística en valles
a partir de eso que fue como que lo que
despertó el interés me me empiezo a
enterar que nuestro país en país
multilingüe donde hay lenguas aborígenes
y que son aún habladas
entonces me esto fue como lo que
despertó el interés y me empecé me
dediqué a para mis estudios
postsecundarios después maestría y
doctorado a una lengua hablada en
argentina que es el wichi entonces a
partir de ahí yo me especializo en esta
lengua indígena y cuando vengo a quebec
porque mi doctorado lo hacía acá sobre
la lengua de argentina
obviamente empiezo a tomar contacto con
lingüistas
[Música]
últimos americanistas que se
especializan en lenguas indígenas en
quebec en canadá y entonces a través
al igual que él y no es una lengua que
también habla del territorio de quebec
que es pariente es como una prima de la
lengua escrita entonces eso al descubrir
lino empiezo a descubrir las estructuras
de la lengua de cría y a través de eso
conozco gente que trabaja con la
provincia con la gente de ontario y
entonces así fui
espero que interesante el camino para
llegar ahí la trayectoria porque no fue
no sé si voy a escribir un libro sobre
la gramática crisis de trabajo y años de
poder también entender la estructura de
la lengua porque para poder hacer la
gramática la gente se sorprende porque
eso no hablo la lengua yo quería
preguntar exactamente yo no hablo la
lengua pero sé cómo funciona la lengua
muchas veces eso les digo porque la
admisión pero entonces como haces una
gramática y luego bueno sería como
mecánico que conoce el funcionamiento de
un coche pero que no sabe manejar algo
así
entonces alguien que puede comprender la
estructura y funcionamiento los valores
de cada uno de los de los elementos de
la gramática exactamente solo que no
necesariamente la tengo que hablar
porque lo que yo quiero mostrar es
justamente cómo funciona la lengua para
la gente que quiere aprenderla y
justamente quienes quieren aprender el
crit demo exacto el creemos es como el
digo es la lengua que se habló
ancestralmente en este territorio en la
región esto es en la bahía se llamaba ya
james la james bay
que ahora está en un estado de perdiz
miento estaba perdiendo se quedan
aproximadamente 200 locutores en la isla
entonces las nuevas generaciones que
conocen la lengua que la conocen por
haberlo escuchado pero ahora no la
hablan la quieren reaprender entonces es
el principal público para quien está
destinado y
lo van a aprender en clases en la
escuela en el secundario o quizás
también en cursos en centros
comunitarios en cosas así y porque una
variante tan específica del crit fue
elegida para realizar este libro que voy
a mostrar hacia la imagen
en realidad fue un pedido de la
comunidad que la comunidad me contratan
para llevar a cabo este proyecto ellos
me hacen un encargo me dicen que haremos
una en realidad la historia es que
empezaron con una publicación de un
diccionario cuando sale el diccionario
en 2014 hubo mucho entusiasmo en la
comunidad y la gente se bueno pero ahora
que sabemos si uno quiere poner las
palabras juntas como hacemos entonces
surgió la necesidad de algo que fuera un
poquito más allá de un diccionario con
reglas y todo
y en realidad hubo una primera versión
de la gramática que acompañaba a la
segunda edición del diccionario entonces
segunda edición dijimos bueno vamos a
agregar al final algo sobre la gramática
pero esta primera versión resultó ser
muy técnica
entonces me pidieron podrías hacer algo
un poquito más
accesible para gente que no tiene
necesariamente conocimiento gramática y
todo eso y entonces por eso se me
ocurrió trabajar a través de historias
de narraciones
son historias tradicionales si en
realidad hay de todo hay una historia
que es tradicional tradicional de
realmente hace mucho tiempo que es
compartida por varias comunidades niños
y también creo que no es éticamente
también en otros pueblos y que fue una
de las primeras historias que se
escribieron las escribió un visionario
generalmente son los misionarios los que
hacen esta tarea al principio y luego
agregamos unas narraciones contadas por
gente de la comunidad porque si no es
una es una tradición tradiciones orales
finales o culturas orales exactamente
entonces lo que hicimos fue transponer
al escrito narraciones de los hablantes
que son la gente los más ancianos que
son los que manejan todavía la lengua
esos han contado historias han contado
también cosas de su vida personal
historias de vida y algunos de esos
extractos son los que estoy usando para
ilustrar los conceptos gramaticales
bueno pues vamos a poner todas las
informaciones con respecto al libro con
respecto a usted su biografía etcétera
en el sitio internet en el artículo así
que abajo de este vídeo van a poder ver
toda la información jimena terraza
muchísimas gracias gracias a ti